really bright and sunny today I can't
unsee the slides but I guess that's okay
hi everyone my name is Maria
for the past four and a half years I've
been building a company called sunbird
Sebert is a fragrance subscription
service and we help people date
fragrances before marrying them I'm
really happy to be here today because
Sunbird is you know it's probably one of
the hardest things that I had to do in
my life but it's also one of the most
rewarding and the YC community has been
instrumental in helping me get to this
point so it's really I'm really happy to
be here today um now I would like to
take you I guess behind the scenes of
how we build the company and some of the
early mistakes we've made and God knows
there were plenty so chapter one of our
story it's called the year of misery I
kid you know that's how I refer to that
time it was the year where I think we
read every book Under the Sun about
building an MVP yet we didn't talk to a
single customer um I'm a huge fragrance
junkie so let me set the story straight
the company was built out of my passion
for the category right I love fragrances
I hate shopping for them you know when
you walk into a store like a thousand
fragrances in the air
the lady is spritzing something in your
face the pushy sales assistant I hated
that the coffee beans don't work long
story short is I had a dream and that
dream was what if I could discover my
next fragrance from the comfort of my
couch the one thing that was missing was
a really good fragrance recommend or
scent recommendation system so my
co-founders and I set out to build one
I took us about so the first landing
page was very quick and I was the
original person who recommended
fragrances I doubt I was really good at
that then we brought technology on board
and I think would build like six
different ways for you to discover
fragrances online this one feature we
call its Smart Search but basically you
can say okay like I won a fragrance for
a workout that smells like oranges and
we basically got your back the problem
was we all decided as founders to quit
our jobs and this was the business model
oh wait a second you cannot really
monetize a recommender can you because
people are not gonna pay you I think it
took us about six months to realize
again it really monetize a
recommendation platform and then we had
to figure out what is it that we can
build that can
actually charge people money for and so
the first idea was well why don't we
build a discovery kit son discovery kit
so it was basically it looked like this
if you can see basically six small
little samples people would pay us nine
dollars for that and the idea was that
if they liked a cent they would purchase
a full-size bottle from us
long story short they purchased the kid
they never really purchased the bottle
so we'll all we made was nine dollars
hope of like a hundred people not really
a billion dollar business so we went
back to the drawing board and mind you
this is we still haven't talked to one
single customer about what is it that
they really truly wanted so we're all
still living in our heads so oh and this
was a fun time for me because we're
operating on a shoestring budget I
basically don't have a job my savings
are dwindling down so I found this
really fun hack you know when you go to
support they give you three samples for
free you know when you go twice that's
six samples you can sell them for nine
dollars it's it's an amazing business
model or not so I feel like I literally
went to all 12 safar's in Manhattan a
few times a day I asked my friends to do
that not fun they like I felt like sales
clark's literally recognized my face
like what is she drinking the fragrances
I don't know next long story short we
moved on to the new business model so we
were like okay well maybe the problem
with our first business model is that it
takes an additional step for people to
buy the full-size bottle so why don't we
shove them the full-size bottles right
away so we came up with this try before
you buy model for fragrances three
full-size bottles of fragrances and
little samples attached to them we would
just shift to people for free obviously
we would recommend them the sons based
on all our algorithm and data and they
had five days to try the fragrances and
ship the full bottles back if they
didn't want any of them so that was a
really fun experience because we saw a
30 percent fraud rate on those but on
that business model so it ship a box and
more often than not it would not come
back and we would then not be able to
charge somebody's card so at the time we
were able to get into an accelerated
program out here in New York called er a
and they give us $40,000 so basically
that's all the money that we had to play
with and I think we wasted about twenty
thousand which is half
I'm trying to make this work and God
very much in the red got very upset um I
think I mean saying that this was blood
sweat and tears is really not saying
much so I think we came to a point where
we came to a point where I think we
really wanted to give up and that's
where we come to chapter 2 the glimmer
of help so you know when the going gets
really hard you call this one person who
you hope is gonna support you so for me
that person was Michael Seibel Michael
is currently now the CEO of the
accelerator program at YC at the time he
was just a successful entrepreneur sold
his company to Autodesk so I tried I
wanted to call Michael to cry on his
shoulder basically I was like Michael
you know fragrance is really suck I
don't think we can make them work I
think we're gonna build a makeup company
he goes like wait what Maria you spent
the last year failing at fragrances
you're telling me that you're gonna go
and build a makeup startup and spend
another year failing at makeup because
like makes no sense no no if I were to
put my money into someone and Orbach a
team that I think has the best potential
to make fragrances work it would be
sunbird something shifted for me and he
thinks sometimes they're only that one
mentor to kind of like hold her a hand
for something when when the going gets
really tough Michael also shifted my
thinking a little bit because he said
Maria what if people are not looking for
a signature fragrance what if they would
like to change fragrances like they
change clothing I was like huh
interesting idea I hung up the phone two
hours later we had the winning business
model and it was a fragrance rental
basically so we said okay full bottles
are not really working for us we keep
just losing money every time we try to
sell full fragrance bottles of fragrance
of perfume so we decided that we are
gonna rent quote-unquote or ship people
a 30 day supply of a design of fragrance
of their choice for under $15 so
basically instead of committing to one
full bottle you can kind of get it in
increments and build your collection and
we decided to make it a subscription so
we basically turned off all the fancy
features in our site it was a one-pager
really ugly looking with this ugly
picture that's why I have it up on the
slide and they
basically it worked like magic people
paid us money first you know which of
them product later amazing we got well
you can't really see the picture but we
got a hundred and five orders in a span
of a week and for us that was like I've
never felt this successful in my life
we were finally making it oh my god now
we had our nine-to-five as like startup
founders um if you can tell from the
picture that's me on the left to my
co-founders after hours we would spritz
perfumes like literally trying to get
them from a big bottle into a little guy
until 2:00 a.m. every day that's how we
fulfill our first orders these are the
little guys all packed up and ready to
go all 105 of them I counted I took them
to the post office myself and then we
get to the real fun part the darkest
hour and that's chapter three the
darkest hour is just before dawn as our
business was scaling well scaling a
hundred customers not really scaling
it's really early on and you know I we
went through an experience of pitching a
demo day at the first accelerator here
in New York nobody really wanted to give
us money and I was looking in our bank
account I think out of the 40,000 that
the first accelerator gave us we had
about 5,000 and e-commerce is a business
that requires a lot of working capital
it requires a lot of cash so I realized
that would have to raise and um for the
longest time it was like the biggest
disconnect because we were looking at
this and this is the the rendition of
like our first version of assembler
dashboard you can hardly tell but
they're like literally 3kp eyes on here
and the most important one is how many
orders a day we're getting so we're
getting ten orders a day for me it's
huge it's like I'm making it but the
rest of the world does not really catch
up you know caught up to that they're
looking at my product they're like it's
kind of ugly wouldn't anybody want this
you know and a lot of investors are like
you know what my wife doesn't use
fragrance I don't think you'll ever be
successful I'm like okay so I I go ahead
and I pitch people I pitched I didn't
count maybe 40 people everybody told me
no but the noes are not the like knows
never really upset me what upset me were
the crappy yeses and I'll tell you what
those are so I was pitching this one
investor couple there were angels and I
told them hey I'm raising two hundred
fifty thousand dollars to get this
company off the ground look it's killing
it
clearly 500 orders yeah and and there
and and they basically took me for a
spin it was like eight meetings sent us
this due diligence sent us that like
built a financial model for us so I was
legitimately thinking they were gonna
give me $250,000 after all of this work
and then we get to the close quote
unquote to that last meeting when I
asked them for the check and they're
like okay Maria we're gonna give you
$25,000 and they promised me a valuation
that was three times lower than the
lowest that I could accept at the time
and they said that they would also want
five percent advisory shares in my
company because they didn't think I was
qualified to run this business I walked
out of that meeting and walked into
another meeting and it was probably even
worse although I don't know it depends
but it was a real estate investor and he
said Maria sunbird is awesome I love
your idea how about you give me 10% of
your company for free office space for a
year for you on your three co-founders I
worked out of that meeting I told both
of them no obviously although at the
time was pretty close actually saying
yes to some of those deals and then I
went back to the only person who I
thought would listen um his name is John
he's an angel investor he doesn't listen
in commerce but for me he was a mentor
and I was always afraid to ask him for
money I would always ask him for advice
I'm like John how do you do this how did
you do that and I thought it was also
the time when we applied for YC by the
way it was the second time that we
applied for YC the first time we got
rejected it was fine I was the wrong
business model anyway I would have
rejected myself many times over um and
basically I came to John and I said John
Sunbird is raising a hundred K I want
you to put all of it and I'm gonna give
you a good deal and the reason you
should do it is a we're growing like
crazy B I'm gonna get into Y Combinator
in three weeks and our valuation is
gonna triple so now is the perfect
timing for you to invest so John wrote
us a check for $100,000 and then that
brings me turn next chapter
Y Combinator well we apply to Y
Combinator for the second time and we
didn't get in so I had to call John back
and say John so no the comp
valuation is not 3x but by the way we
have another 500 customers so you should
be really happy because we're basically
a rocket ship and then I had to go back
to the drawing board and start and keep
raising money basically because we
needed more working capital to build
inventory and one thing though I think I
discovered with that experience with
John is the rule of skaar City because
all I said was hey I have a hundred K
and I want you to fill that whole
hundred K there is no room for anybody
left in that round so what I ended up
doing afterwards is every investor pitch
that I had I I would come in and say hey
so sunbirds round is 150 thousand I
already have a hundred in my bank so all
I have left in the round is 50k do you
want to be the last 50 K in so I pitched
six people and like funds and I think I
got five yeses out of that so that kind
of really gets you over that like 150
real quick and so I think that the big
lesson learned there is you know if
you're going for like a million say
you're really going for one quarter of
that and then just keep over subscribing
eventually you'll get to that million
but um you know I again a lot of my
mentors a lot of my friends are you know
Y Combinator alumns and although the
business was growing I still didn't feel
about the DNA of the company was there
and we truly had the product market fit
on some level and so a lot of my friends
were like Maria are you applying to I
see and I'm like what a third time to
get rejected a third time I did apply to
YC and long story short we got in hence
they invited me to speak here cuz you
know if I didn't get in for a third time
probably wouldn't make it to this stage
but basically was the best experience of
our life we moved out at California and
I really think it changed the DNA of our
company so hyper focus on growth not
like yearly growth and quarterly growth
week over week over week over week and
when you get go through that experience
you always feel like in your batch every
company is growing faster than you and
everybody is smarter than you but by the
way you walk out were like the best
peers and the best friends out of this
and the one thing that YC also taught us
is to have true user interviews to
really try to understand what people
think and then this one funny one that's
stuck with me it was probably one of the
first ones somewhere in the Palo Alto
area we met with this lady in a coffee
shop she wasn't a user of the product
and
like hey we wanted to meet with you see
what you think about our product she
goes like are you dying is some bird
going out of business is that why you're
talking to me I bet your dad don't die
please don't die I'm gonna buy 10
subscriptions I'm like what she clearly
cared and that was like probably the
most that was probably the first time
when I truly realized we might just make
it because when people are willing to
like just pay you 10 acts just like
don't die please it's you know you kind
of know that you're building something
that people want and now chapter 5 life
after YC you know for most companies are
kind of like end up making it the bigger
chunk of their life would be post YC not
prior um I kind of wanted to leave you
with a couple of last thoughts some of
the things that you know I wish I knew
or I just need to remind myself so the
first one is surround yourself with 10x
people and what I mean by 10x it's not
like 10 times more people there is this
basically you know concepts like in more
traditional industries somebody who's
really top of their game is just about
maybe 2 times better than your average
person in startups because it's like
really out-of-the-box thinking really
creative top people the creme de la
creme like if the smartest people are 10
times better than your average person
and I wish I knew that when I started
hiring my team because I would always go
for the cheapest person like you know oh
you're cheap and you're kind of
hard-working
welcome to Sanford you know and I was
like well I could have hired probably
three times less people just hired the
10x people and we would have probably
gone thathe
ahead so that's the one - it actually
has been said before here today have an
ad asia's dream and not just having a
daesh's dream communicated kind of like
come out tell the world of it is your
dream because when you do your help
about right so and you know the world
actually can get on board with you I
think as women we do tend to be very shy
and that sentiment has been shared here
today you know pronouncing the billion
billion word is really hard but I think
we have to I mean I've heard pitches
from when were like we're gonna be 50%
of this industry like in three years and
I'm like yeah you're really bummed but
you know as women we kind of prefer
together first and then say
that we really wanted to hit that target
I think we have to start reversing our
thinking and first kind of like setting
that audacious goal communicating it to
the team to the partners to everyone and
then hating it then last but not least
which is also a big lesson learned for
me don't take advice from people that
don't have what you want I don't know
how many of you were building your
companies I certainly when I got started
I felt everybody wanted to give me
advice from you know my mom and I do
welcome her advice to everybody else you
know friends and family and everybody
and one of the conversations really
stuck with me so it was my successful
friend she has built a business like a
hedge fund very rich and so I told her
hey you know I kind of want to build
this tech startup in a fragrance world
and she goes like have you ever worked
for a fragrance company do you even know
what like you know I'm like no I have
not worked her fragrance company but I
think I might just make it and basically
she was she was very discouraging and
I'm really happy I didn't listen because
in that moment I was this close to going
like you know maybe I should apply to
L'Oreal and like spend my next 10 years
working for like $60,000 a year or
something and being really miserable at
my desk I'm really happy I didn't so in
other words only take advice from people
who have I have what you want in life
just you know to like wrap this up um
Sandberg has come a really long way
we're now a team of about a hundred
people we're shipping fragrances to
about 250,000 people in the United
States we are eventually going to expand
international we've raised about 25
million people but 25 million dollars
not people luckily yeah and I think that
a lot of a lot of what we accomplished
is definitely thanks to YC so if you
guys are running companies and you
haven't applied it I strongly encourage
you to do so it'll change your life
thank you so much for your attention
you